la policía detuvo manifestantes en la
universidad llamé amilia islamia de
Nueva Delhi los estudiantes iban a ver
el documental de la bbc sobre el Primer
Ministro magendra modi
pero las autoridades universitarias
querían prohibir la proyección
el rector ha ordenado cerrar las puertas
para impedir que los estudiantes
circulen los comedores están cerrados y
no se nos permite entrar en algunas
puertas
las tensiones entre los problemas
religiosos aumentan día a día no podemos
permitir que esto vuelva ocurrir porque
sabemos Cuál es la verdad sabemos lo que
el Primer Ministro está haciendo a la
sociedad a los Estados y a todo no
podemos permitir que esto vuelva a
ocurrir otra Universidad de la capital
cortó la electricidad e internet en su
campus antes de su proyección y una
universidad de heide Bad en el sur de
India ha ordenado una investigación
después de que los estudiantes
proyectaran el documental la federación
de estudiantes de India planea
proyectarlo en todos lados del país la
primera parte del documental de la bbc
India de Mary question aborda el
episodio más controvertido de la carrera
política de modi cuando era ministro
principal del estado de guajará de
occidental en 2002 en aquel momento más
de 1000 personas murieron en disturbios
antimusulmanes YouTube y Twitter han
accedido a la petición de retirar los
enlaces al documental Desatando las
críticas de partidos de la oposición y
grupos de Derechos Humanos que dicen que
es un ataque a la libertad de prensa
India ocupa actualmente el puesto 150 de
180 países en la clasificación de
libertad de prensa reporteros que
publica anualmente la clasificación
acusa al gobierno de modi de silenciar
las críticas algo que altos dirigentes
del partido gobernante han negado